Bonjour! Savez-vous ce qu'est une cour princière?
-Alors, il y a plusieurs sens possibles, mais...
-Non, mais c'était une question rhétorique.
Si pour vous, une cour princière ressemble
à ceci cour de récré avec des princes on
a du pain sur la planche. Et si vous êtes
déjà en train de penser à Versailles, désolé,
on est toujours médiévistes ici!
-Que trépasse si je faiblis!
Dans cet épisode on fera la différence et
on expliquera les termes de cour princière
et d'hôtel princier à la fin du Moyen-Âge.
Déjà, le mot cour peut avoir plusieurs sens.
«Tenir sa cour», pour un prince, peut
signifier rendre la justice. Il peut aussi
s'agir de l'entourage du roi ou du prince,
c'est le sens de «court» en anglais,
mais en allemand la cour, qui se dit «hof»,
désigne plutôt le lieu où elle se réunit.
En français, c'est donc un peu le bordel
puisque le mot cour peut prendre ces différents
sens.
-Généralement, la cour, ça reste quand
même l'entourage du prince, sa famille, des
nobles plus ou moins hauts placés... C'est
un peu son gang, sa team.
-Et comme tout groupe, il arrive que ses membres
soient modifiés au gré des besoins, de la
vie, etc. Lors de certaines occasions, comme
les cours plaignières, la cour peut être
composée d'énormément de monde. Et à l'inverse,
ce nombre est parfois réduit quand il ne
se passe pas grand chose.
La définition de la cour reste donc vague,
et c'était déjà le cas au Moyen-Âge, comme
le montre cette citation du XIIe siècle de
Walter Map: «A la cour j’existe et
de la cour je parle mais ce qu’est la cour,
dieu sait que je n’en sais rien.»
Les membres de la cour ne sont donc pas fixes,
et durant le Moyen-Âge ces cours restent
itinérantes parce que les princes adorent
se déplacer de château en château. A chaque
déplacement, le prince emporte donc tout
ce petit monde avec toutes leurs affaires,
d'où l'importance d'avoir du mobilier facile
à déplacer.
-Merci de penser un peu aux serviteurs dans
cette histoire.
-Justement, pour assurer le bon fonctionnement
de cette cour, il fallait bien du personnel,
et c'est ainsi qu'on arrive à notre deuxième
définition: l'hôtel princier.
-Attention, comme pour la cour, le terme d'hôtel
peut avoir deux sens. Le premier, qu'on ne
détaillera pas, peut désigner une résidence
médiévale, et donc le lieu de résidence
du prince. On trouve ainsi de nombreux hôtels
princiers à Paris dès le XIIIe siècle.
-Mais le terme d'hôtel désigne également
l'institution qui regroupe les serviteurs
d'un prince, et c'est à eux qu'on va s'intéresser
aujourd'hui.
-Quels métiers pratiquent-ils, comment sont-ils
payés, qui sont ces gens, quels sont leurs
réseaux?
-Contrairement à la cour, l'hôtel princier
est une réalité administrative, dont on
retrouve des traces dans plusieurs types de
documents:
Les ordonnances de l'hôtel, qui sont des
descriptions de l'organisation de l'hôtel
et de ses différents membres, et les différents
documents de comptabilité. Parmi eux on trouve
par exemple les écrous de la dépense, qui
sont de petites bandes de parchemin qui récapitulent
les dépenses de la journée.
Avant de détailler davantage, on peut donc
résumer comme ceci: la cour princière
est composée d'un prince, de son hôtel,
de plein d'autres personnages importants,
et de leurs hôtels plus petits. Ça fait
un paquet de monde.
Le plus vieux texte régissant l'organisation
d'un hôtel princier nous vient d'Henri Ier
Beauclerc, le fils de Guillaume le Conquérant.
Il s'appelle la Constitutio Domus Regis, ou
organisation de la maison du roi, et date
des années 1130. Dans ce texte on retrouve
les noms des différents membres de l'hôtel,
ce qui est pratique car tout le monde avait
tendance à essayer de s'y incruster.
-Non mais je vous jure, je travaille ici.
Je connais quelqu'un dans le château! J'ai
un tonneau à l'intérieur...
-Au fil du temps ce type de textes prend le
nom d'ordonnance de l'hôtel, et remplace
définitivement la tradition orale à partir
du XIIIe siècle. On y retrouve les fonctions
précises des serviteurs, qui obéissent à
une hiérarchie, leurs devoirs, mais aussi
leurs droits.
L'un des premiers hôtels bien définis en
France est celui du comté de Hainaut, au
début du XIIIe siècle. C'est un comté bien
développé, composé de nombreux nobles,
et donc bien organisé administrativement.
On trouve l'organisation de son hôtel dans
le Ministeria curiae Hanoniensis, les offices
de la cour de Hainaut, écrit par le chancelier
de Hainaut Gilbert de Mons en 1212.
Déjà, ce dernier nous explique que le comté
de Hainaut est divisé en trois circonscriptions:
Mons, Valenciennes et Ostrevant. Il existe
donc une cour du Hainaut, mais trois hôtels
pour chacune de ces circonscriptions. Ces
trois hôtels sont dirigés par trois officiers
au dessus de la division en circonscriptions:
-Le sénéchal héréditaire, d'abord, est
le chef des valets du prince. On l'appelle
aussi le Dapifer.
-Le chambellan héréditaire, ensuite, veille
sur le prince en particulier, son corps et
ses biens.
-Et enfin le bouteiller héréditaire est
celui qui s'occupe de l'approvisionnement
en boissons, parce qu'il est toujours important
d'avoir une bonne réserve de vin à portée
de main.
-Ces trois officiers sont donc au dessus des
circonscriptions, et en dessous d'eux se trouvent
plusieurs autres offices héréditaires qui
sont à chaque fois en trois exemplaires pour
les trois circonscriptions. Il y a par exemple
le panetier, qui fait le pain, et l'emptor
escarum qui est chargé d'acheter la nourriture.
-Vous ne rêvez pas, la plupart des offices
tournent autour de la bouffe. Normal.
-Chacun de ces serviteurs a des droits et
des devoirs. Par exemple, le chambellan peut
prendre une robe et un manteau de chaque chevalier
qui est au service du comte de Hainaut. Le
comte devait aussi fournir des chevaux à
ses officiers, ainsi que des gages. De l'argent.
Les offices héréditaires se transmettaient
de père en fils, mais pouvaient aussi êtres
cédées contre de l'argent si le comte était
d'accord.
-Les bons comtes font les bons amis.
A la différence du comté de Hainaut, l'hôtel
royal des capétiens ne contient pas d'offices
héréditaires, le roi peut librement virer
ses serviteurs.
On trouve des traces des hôtels royaux dès
Saint-Louis, au XIIIe siècle, et ils sont
très bien organisés, à tel point que la
plupart des hôtels princiers des XIVe et
XVe siècles s'en inspirent.
L'hôtel royal a sa propre comptabilité,
la première ordonnance de l'hôtel royal
conservée date de 1261. On en retrouve ensuite
pour chaque changement dans l'organisation.
Grâce à ces ordonnances, on sait quels offices
formaient l'hôtel et combien chacun était
payé.
Les offices étaient divisés en six métiers
principaux: la paneterie, pour la fabrication
du pain; l'échansonnerie, pour le vin;
la cuisine, la fruiterie, l'écurie et la
chambre.
-A la tête de ces métiers se trouvent des
chefs de service qui sont plusieurs, afin
d'éviter qu'une seule personne travaille
365 jours par ans.
-Par exemple, si on détaille un métier au
choix: celui de la cuisine, d'après l'ordonnance
de l'hôtel de 1291. On trouve six queux,
les maîtres cuisiniers, qui se relaient donc
à la tête du service. En dessous d'eux se
trouvent 5 aides de cuisine, deux sauciers,
4 souffleurs qui entretiennent les feux, 7
hâteurs, ceux qui sont spécialisés dans
la cuisson, 8 pages, qui font un peu de tout,
et 2 huissiers qui gardent la porte. Ça fait
donc déjà 35 serviteurs pour un métier.
Au total, d'après cette ordonnance, il y
avait 164 serviteurs dans l'hôtel royal,
mais ça, c'est le chiffre minimum car certains
de ces serviteurs avaient eux-même des valets
qui n'apparaissent pas dans les comtes.
On estime qu'il y avait plutôt environ 500
serviteurs, plus 200 pour les hôtels de la
reine et des enfants royaux.
-Ça fait à peu près 700 personnes, mais
ils n'étaient pas tous là en même temps.
-A cela s'ajoutent les hôtels de tous les
membres de la cour du roi, ça fait donc:
du monde. Et du monde qui coûte cher.
En 1250 les dépenses annuelles de l'hôtel
royal représentent environ 36 000 livres.
Ça ne vous évoque peut-être pas grand chose,
mais dès 1299 ces dépenses annuelles grimpent
à 250 000 livres, soit beaucoup plus, et
ce chiffre grimpe encore régulièrement sous
les Valois, au XIVe siècle.
L'importance de ces sommes s'explique déjà
par le fait que les serviteurs recevaient
un salaire régulier, les gages, qui dépend
du nombre de chevaux que le serviteur a à
entretenir: plus le serviteur est important,
plus il possède de chevaux, et donc plus
on lui donne d'argent pour nourrir ses chevaux.
Les gages ne permettent pas de mettre de l'argent
de côté.
Les serviteurs les plus importants, comme
le chambellan, reçoivent donc une pension
annuelle en plus des gages.
-Il y avait quand même aussi quelques bonus.
Déjà, beaucoup de serviteurs étaient nourris
aux frais du roi, on disait qu'ils avaient
«bouche à cour». On fournissait aussi
à certains des chandelles, des draps, des
vêtements tous les ans, etc.
-En plus de ça, le roi ou le prince pouvait
offrir des cadeaux extraordinaires, lors d'événements
importants par exemple. Il pouvait arriver
qu'un prince donne des gages exceptionnels
à ses serviteurs pauvres pour qu'ils puissent
se confesser à Pâques, parce qu'il fallait
faire un don après la confession. Les autres
dons exceptionnels ont lieu lors du mariage
d'un serviteur, du baptême de ses enfants,
de son départ en retraite... Le prince paie
aussi pour son serviteur s'il est capturé,
et fait l'objet d'une rançon; il peut rembourser
les chevaux du serviteur morts au service
du prince, et il finance enfin l'enterrement
et la messe de ses serviteurs décédés.
Dans cette dernière partie, qui sera plutôt
longue, on va détailler les différents métiers
qu'on pouvait trouver dans un hôtel princier.
Et comme on n'a absolument aucun parti pris,
on va prendre l'exemple de l'hôtel ducs de
Bourgogne. Au hasard.
-Déjà, il y a le chambellan, le personnage
le plus proche du duc. Il possède une office
héréditaire, et est responsable des valets
de chambre qui sont forcément des hommes
de confiance allant parfois jusqu'à dormir
aux pieds du duc. Les chambellans sont toujours
issus de la noblesse, du moins à la cour
de Bourgogne, et sont supervisés par le grand
chambellan.
-Être chambellan, c'est l'office la plus
classe, l'élite de la cour. Il arrive même
que le duc nomme des personnes chambellans
à titre honorifique, sans qu'elles servent,
juste parce que c'est classe.
-En dessous des chambellans se trouvent les
maîtres d'hôtel, qui supervisent le travail
des serviteurs.
Ensuite vient le service de la cuisine, très
important parce que manger, c'est bien. On
y trouve les queux, les cuisiniers, des garçons
de cuisine, des sauciers, des apprentis, mais
aussi des écuyers de cuisine qui doivent
veiller au garde-manger et tenir les comptes
de ce qui est consommé chaque jour.
Les queux pouvaient eux-même acheter leurs
aliments au marché, ou passer par des fournisseurs,
notamment pour les viandes et les poissons.
Ils avaient sous leur autorité toute une
panoplie de serviteurs spécialisés dont
certains que j'ai déjà cités: les hâteurs
pour surveiller la cuisson, les souffleurs
et bûchers qui entretiennent le feu, les
potagiers qui font la soupe, les sauciers
qui font les sauces, les porteurs qui nettoient
et transportent les ingrédients... Une cuisine
peut compter jusqu'à 17 postes différents.
A la cour de Bourgogne, on compte 29 personnes
dans ce service en 1426.
-Et c'est que le début des réjouissances
puisque le service suivant est celui de la
paneterie, donc: encore de la nourriture.
-Ce service est constitué de panetiers, qui
ne se contentent pas de faire le pain mais
doivent aussi superviser l'achat des fournitures
de la table comme le linge de table, et bien
sûr l'achat du blé s'il n'y en a pas assez
dans les greniers du duc. Avec tout ça ils
réalisent deux types de pain: un pain de
bouche pour les nobles, et un pain de commun
pour les pécores. Euh, le personnel.
-Ils sont assistés de sommeliers de la paneterie
qui sont chargés de l'approvisionnement en
beurre, fromage, vinaigre, hypocras... Et
d'oublieurs, qui fabriquent les oublis, des
pâtisseries.
-Des quoi?
-J'ai oublié...
-Passons donc au service suivant: la bouteillerie,
service essentiel lui aussi. Le bouteiller
du duc y est assisté de valets de la bouteillerie
et veille à l'approvisionnement en vin, produit
directement par les vignes du duc bien entendu.
On est quand même en Bourgogne. Ce service
compte aussi des écuyers échansons, avec
à sa tête le premier échanson qui choisit
les vins du prince et peut les vendre s'ils
ne sont plus bons.
-Oui parce qu'à mon époque on boit le vin
direct après la récolte. Le laisser vieillir,
c'est surfait. On a pas le temps.
-Dans ce service on trouve aussi des barilliers,
des sommeliers qui servent le vin et font
le compte de la boisson consommée chaque
jour, pratique en cas de contrôle, des porteurs
de vin, etc.
C'est aussi ce service qui veille à l'approvisionnement
en verre et en vaisselle précieuse.
Enfin, le dernier gros service de l'hôtel
est celui de la maréchaussée, c'est à dire
l'écurie. Dans ce service on trouve une forge
et une soixantaine de chevaux, donc ça nécessite
forcément un peu de personnel.
Comme il existe trois types de chevaux, il
y a trois types de valets. Les valets des
palefrois s'occupent des chevaux de parade,
les valets des sommiers entretiennent les
chevaux de transport et les valets des grands
chevaux s'occupent des
-Grands chevaux!
-Des chevaux de guerre. Ceux qu'on appelle
aussi les «destriers».
On trouve donc dans ce service des écuyers
qui s'occupent des chevaux, de leur achat
et de leur entretien, et également des palefreniers
et des maréchaux-ferrants.
Un peu à part, on trouve des chevaucheurs
des écuries: ce sont des cavaliers professionnels
qui ont pour fonction de porter des messages.
Et si vous n'avez toujours pas trouvé de
métier qui vous intéresse parmi tout ça,
pas de soucis, il reste des tas de professions
qu'on ne citera pas toutes.
-Il y a le service de la table, avec les écuyers
tranchants qui tranchent la viande pour le
prince, et les pages qui font le service.
-Les médecins, physiciens, chirurgiens et
barbiers, qui sont tous rangés ensemble parce
qu'ils s'occupent du corps du prince. Ils
doivent donc être des hommes de confiance,
surtout les barbiers qui pourraient facilement
rater leur coup.
-Le cou du prince, plutôt?
-Certains médecins sont très proches du
prince et peuvent même travailler comme astrologues
à côté, mais c'est une autre histoire que
j'ai déjà racontée.
-Il y a aussi des légistes, qui sont formés
en droit, et des secrétaires qui s'occupent
des documents du prince.
-Les membres de la chambre aux deniers, responsables
des recettes et des dépenses du prince.
-Les officiers d'armes, très importants!
On trouve dans ce service les hérauts d'armes
qui connaissent les armoiries de tout le monde,
ce qui est très utile lors des tournois,
mais ça aussi on en a déjà parlé.
-Et enfin, les membres de la chapelle ducale.
Là encore c'est une fonction très importante,
le duc possède une chapelle à demeure, dans
son palais, mais aussi une chapelle domestique
chargée de le suivre dans ses déplacements.
Selon les époques et les événements elle
est plus ou moins développée, on trouve
une «petite chapelle» pour les services
simples et une grosse chapelle avec des chanteurs,
des enfants de chœur.... Pour les grands
événements religieux.
Ce qui est amusant avec la chapelle, c'est
que pour avoir les meilleurs chapelains, on
pouvait facilement en piquer aux autres. C'est
comme ça que Philippe le Hardi, qui voyage
régulièrement à Rome, débauche en leur
proposant un meilleur salaire 3 membres de
la chapelle pontificale en 1391, puis à nouveau
4 en 1394 et un dernier en 1395. A la fin,
les papes devaient un peu faire la gueule.
Même si je me suis basée sur l'exemple des
ducs de Bourgogne, cette organisation en différents
services, avec des métiers très précis
à l'intérieur de ces services reste représentative
de l'ensemble des hôtels princiers aux XIV-XVe
siècles. Il peut y avoir des différences,
des exceptions, mais on peut voir par là
que l'hôtel était un organisme bien délimité,
institutionnalisé, avec généralement ses
propres finances.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a intéressés
parce qu'il prêtait un peu moins à rire
que d'habitude, et était surtout plus technique.
Déjà que les définitions de cour princière
et d'hôtel princier n'étaient pas évidentes,
même à l'époque, il y avait en plus une
énorme liste de métiers à citer. C'est
pour ça que j'ai viré la romaine dans cet
épisode aussi, c'est pas son époque du tout,
elle aurait fait que nous embrouiller.
-Je valide totalement.
-En tout cas le prochain épisode sera plus
festif, et plus attrayant, mais comme on restera
dans l'environnement des cours princières
médiévales il me semblait utile de commencer
par faire celui-là.
Rendez-vous donc le mois prochain pour un
nouveau Chroniques de Prof, aurevoir!